vice president harris spoke today with
the president of guatemala
one of the first since actions since she
was put in charge of the diplomatic
efforts to end the massive
immigration surge into the u.s this
comes
as president biden receives an
increasing share of the blame
for the border crisis white house
correspondent peter ducey has details
tonight
the vice president's effort to stop the
flow of illegal immigrants into the
country today
a chat with the president of guatemala
virtually
i'm honored to meet with you i look
forward to traveling to guatemala and
meeting with you in person
and currently our plan is to to come
there in the month of june
harris took that zoom call from her
ceremonial office she still hasn't been
to the border but says she wants to
yes we're working on the plan to get
there we have to deal with covet issues
covet issues have not prevented the vice
president from traveling to
other states on official business so why
is this different what is she referring
to
well i would certainly have to ask her
team about that specifically but i would
tell you also that
her focus is not on the border it's on
addressing the root causes in the
northern triangle republican critics
aren't buying that
that's the excuse that this
administration's going to use
and look at her she's been jet setting
around this country going to all the
different blue states talking about this
this infrastructure plan and everything
else so
no this isn't covered kamala and you
know it
border security is worse today than in
2018 according to 46 percent of
registered voters in a fox news poll
just 15 percent say border security is
better
and 56 say biden's election is either
completely or
mostly the reason there's been an
increase of migrants at the border
as republicans say he's not reaching out
we're going to hit 100 days
i have not met with the president one
time nor had one conversation with him
the white house doubts that's breaking
through do you think tens of millions of
people are concerned about him not
meeting with kevin mccarthy
but as the president preps a national
address to take credit for milestones he
thinks he's reached
republicans want him to take
responsibility for something else
we have a crisis at a border that he
created
lawmakers are going to be listening for
on wednesday in the president's first
joint address uh session remarks to a
joint session
of congress jensaki says that for the
next
two days the president is going to be
very involved
in crafting that speech we did not see
him
on purse uh in person or on camera today
a very limited number of lawmakers are
going to see him
in person on wednesday night because of
the pandemic and we've learned that just
one supreme court justice is going to be
in attendance
because of that reason and it is going
to be the chief justice john
roberts brett peter ducey live on the
north lawn peter thank you